et tout d'un coup un déboulé de gendarme
dans les couloirs du Palais Bourbon pour
une après-midi parlementaire électrique
osceptique dans l'hémicycle se devait
être un débat sur le réchauffement
climatique d'avant Copenhague mais
l'association Greenpeace va imposer sa
signature à sa façon une banderole est
rapidement déployée où l'on peut lire
aux actes monsieur le Président une
militante s'offre même une descente en
rappel qui sont parvenus
ambiance volcanique alors que les
députés Verts encouragent les
perturbateurs je voudrais dénoncer les
pratiques de voyous
qui viennent de se dérouler
dans le cœur de la démocratie quand je
vois comment on attire l'attention par
mode de diversion sur l'immigration sur
les minarets sur l'identité nationale
alors que le défi climatique n'a jamais
été aussi important je pense que les
militants de Greenpeace ont eu raison de
nous rappeler alors voilà